[Musica]
e normale la mappa
a parte il fatto che devo andare in
navigation e soprattutto fatto apposta
come se lo sapesse pazzesco
no sto male raga maniere al contrario lo
re 9 finissimo e quindi noi ragazzi che
si intestava non ho più il cervello
il ragazzo sia assurdo non so veramente
capendo no malaga in trip al cervello e
mamma è servita il feeling è una mappa
diversa continuamente infatti esatto e
come discorso allora mimuto ciao ciao
ok è roba di morto in elettrica che in
noi perché ci stavo io né l'ex imam e
dovevo braga vediamo che cacchio succede
secondo me mimì in groppa tantissimo che
noia io dico che comunque no scusami non
sto capendo niente della mappa salute
l'uso le bolle
poi ho fatto però è strano sa bene buzz
chi è il signor il signor cento cioè non
ho capito se con noi a vista coprendo se
non mi ha veramente perché potrebbe non
avermi vistosa e sai che non lo so
perché la mappa il contrario mi in trip
alla faccia non capisco una sega di
quello che succede
no ma non si può giocare c'è il
giocabile non sto capendo niente è
proprio la mappa al contrario che tti
editing trippa al cervello è una maniera
incredibile comunque valsa potei
gigantesco a chiudere la stanza appena
entra uno sap chiudo cantato facciamo
così
no sono capirlo adesso non posso più di
vedere porco del demonio maledetto sono
stupido o e morale ma non marci
c'era marbella grande dovevo fare l'ho
capito
non si capisce io ho fatto quello col
cappello verde
io non ho mai capito per quale motivo
vengono votati sempre quelli che non
parlano mai
[Musica]
meno male raga meno male mi sono unite
ai voti era l'unico modo per buttarlo
fuori un altro po non è male ma che la
mappa storta portafortuna xvi a supersic
yo no comunque non si capisce veramente
una fava per non sono anche come sia
possibile che io sia stato in grado di
fare tutto sto casino finora perché sono
ho già letto parecchio per pur essendo
un nuovo della mappa non ho veramente
capito se poi che noi aveva coperto se
come norma visto la pena perché noi anno
ma che noia piuttosto che copre qualcuno
veramente chiude il canale quindi
secondo me non mi ha veramente visto
avuto solo un culo abissale perché
secondo me sarebbe stato motivato
veniamo cesca a mettere elettrica enel
madonna che casino mi viene da vomitare
nessuno è andato elettrica ma come
nessuno avessi io vessicchio elettrica
ok
insomma una doppia doppia siamo a una
doppia doppia con la doppia dai
vessicchio
fujio nocivo segreti e stavo archistar e
morto prima che muccino sexy ho detto
che mi alleno che fai la doppia non ci
stiamo a roma da limina curiosità ma mi
hai visti uscire dalla botola ho mai
visto soprano noti ha visto solo sopra
per allora ho avuto un cooper che sono
uscito esattamente contro gli ho detto
dobbiamo mi ha preso e ho già perso
[Musica]
mei tempesta per i lavoratori metta che
se preferisca l'impostore se volessi
curva medesimo ti va bene allora la
gente sa già che sono uscito ok non si
capisce un cazzo
dove devo andare la mappa al contrario
chi l'ha fatta mannaggia non si capisce
una sega ok
ve la racconto semplicemente io c'ho un
tasto quando è parte la partita lo
schiaccio e quindi mi imbuto così la
gente non mi sente quando voglio parlare
con voi parlo con voi quando voglio
farmi sentire schiacciato tasto di
business of però ho sbagliato ho
sbagliato a buttarvi all'inizio era
almeno ancora mai successo strano e
perché chi già è una cosa molto facile
da sbagliare non mi era ancora mai
successo
e invece e invece l'altro è molto strano
perché la ma perche fatta al contrario
quindi anche quando ti muovi era vabbè è
aperta non si capisce una sega prova
abbiamo complete
ok cosa che abbiamo da fare qua machine
si sono scissi ragazzi dopo tante cose
mannaggia
no no io sono pulito pulito detto l'ha
detto ai video allora io ero lì in
reactor che sto facendo il mio memory e
poi esco dal memory c'è il cadaverino
proviamo a far pensare che fossi tu non
ci crederai quindi quindi il mondo ma in
quella zona mi sembrava di aver
intravisto vessicchio
ahia ahia reaktor fa i numeri ma anni
prima io che faccio numeri poi sono
sceso sotto l'onda valerio africa alla
rubrica gusto
bisognerebbe riuscire a dare un'occhiata
ai reati ragazzi il problema è che
adesso devo tornare lì a farla tasche
perché se non riesco a farla il mio
essere non è tranquillo
secondo me non è marcio xke march quando
è lui fa sempre un po più casino c'è
parla parecchio di fiumi sono meno ne
magari è un aspetto totalmente sbagliato
allora quando non ha niente da fare non
si capisce niente
se adesso faccio queste badin elettrica
io con sono convinto che ci sara uno
morto ma convinto anzi forse anche prima
di arrivare in elettrica no
madonna cos'è successo di auto e moto
alcune elettrica
no non c'è nessuna attenzione non c'è
nessuno elettrica di security 9 di sta
seguendo e lui lo è lui l'eroe togliti
ace march qui è un ora che mi segue
stato orribile marce ma che cacchio fa
mar di ragazzi march non può essere che
fermo prescindere poi magari è un modo
per farsi fare non sospettare di se
stesso il fatto che stia fermo all'ora
poi devo fare questo mi piace detto
qualcosa la security madonna il fatto
che sia tutto specchiate orribile allora
mi mancano due task in tutto ciò una e
mezza messi come la conta sbagliatissima
mi chiamo sindaco pace finiscono nelle
spiagge diritto tecnica
porco del demonio lo sapevo pure lo
sapevo pure che ci sarei finito secolo
sapevo pure
[Musica]